Layouts are the essence of how to create beautiful and modern applications for users
But if you are not careful
Your stunning layouts can lead to a significant drain on performance
My name is Colt McCannless
And if you use some luxury features on the display layouts
It is possible to fall into trouble
Remember that any time the size and location of the object changes in the display hierarchy
There may be implications for other layouts in the view
For example, if the button size doubles suddenly you may need to move an adjacent viewing window
And then of course, there may be a need to change the size of the father display window as a result
Note, there is a small set of properties for the View window which when changed
Requires a pipeline layout phase to occur before screen refresh
Basically this phase is cut through the hierarchy of the display
Calculates the correct locations and sizes for all display windows affected by the change
In general, this is a fairly quick process
But if they are not attentive they can launch an expensive chain of planning processes
Which can gradually and quickly withdraw to your frame time
A good example of this is the relative planning container
Basically, this chart allows you to define the location of the view window
For the location of another view window in the hierarchy
For example, always stay to the right of the script box
Or at the top of the current container, or stay at the top of the top brother
But always to the right of my brothers in my container
And such strange things
The issue here is that in order to place a view window in position for another view window
The container must begin a second charting process
Before you can finalize the sites and move to the view
Basically, it works as follows
In the first pass you will visit the display windows and calculate their positions and sizes
Based on their personal requests
The relative chart then uses this data
To identify potential locations of interconnected display windows or any weight-bearing sizes
Then adjusts the border accordingly
At this point, the second traffic to the chart begins to determine the final location to be used for the display
The result is that two complete planning processes across all the children in the container
Just get things on the screen
The trick is that this happens every time a change occurs in an associated chart
But be careful here
It is not the only container that can produce this double-planning behavior
For example, linear planning generally produces only one layout request
Until you add the measurement with the coefficient of the eldest son
In this case, you can end up needing to start a second planning pass
For proper sizes
The network layout has a very similar problem
This container allows relative positioning but avoids double taxation
By manipulating the windows of children's display windows
It's great, is not it?
I mean, you can get all the functions of a linked chart container
Without any cost to perform
You can get all the jobs
All this is disposed of at any time when the layout is filled with gravity
Or in some cases, if the weights are used in the wrong places
And then of course you will fall into the same performance problem
Now by themselves, many layouts of these containers
Will not have a performance burden
But putting them in the wrong place may cause you great problems.
For example, any time you have root elements in the display hierarchy
Or when the container has a deep hierarchy beneath it.
Or when there is a lot of them swarming the screen like the display menu
Basically, this problem can be exacerbated along the hierarchy
Imagine the relative layout at the top of the display hierarchy
Who will be maneuvering on the planning
Then later, you had a list displayed below containing a series of grid layouts within it
Basically, the final nodes in this configuration
They may end up planning on them 8 times each
Obviously you've got the best places that you can consume frame time
So are we looking to avoid the problem of double layouts?
Here are some useful tips
First, you can track whether the charts use your frame rate
By taking a serious look at the Systrace tool
If you see that the plot / measurement quotas from a view window are unusually high
There is a high probability that they consume frame rate in a bad way
Second, try to reduce the depth of your hierarchy
Note that dual layouts can not be avoided at times
So reduce the depth of your hierarchical view
Will help to minimize their impact on your overall frame rate
Thirdly, avoid calling design requests in any situations
It is not necessary to do so
When a window displays a layout request, you will launch a layout with all its parents
Although there is a large cache in this part of the system
To try to make it as fast as possible it is possible to keep the process very expensive
Fourth, watch the rest of the Android performance patterns videos
Fifth, join our community on Google+
Ask other performance experts.
Remember, keep calm, write your code, and always remember, performance is important.